[Music]
good morning everyone we begin with
breaking news from overnight and what
could be
a very worrying development in ukraine
it verified a report of a possible
chemical attack
in the besieged city of mariopol this
the tweet from the foreign secretary
she says reports that russian forces may
have used chemical agents in an attack
on the people of mariopol we are working
urgently with partners to verify details
any use of such weapons would be a
callous escalation in this conflict and
we will hold putin and his regime to
account
reaction from the u.s as well the
pentagon press secretary say they're
aware of the reports that russian forces
have deployed a potential chemical
munition in mariopol john kirby says if
true it's deeply concerning the city's
mayor says more than 10 000 civilians
have died he said that that number could
surpass 20 000 as weeks of attacks and
probation leave bodies carpeted through
the streets in his words
his comments come as russian forces
continue to turn their attention to the
east of ukraine with pictures emerging
of soldiers from the next people's
republic militia conscript moving
through the city of mariopol in his
nightly address to the ukrainian people
the president vladimir zelinsky warned
of the threat of russian chemical
attacks
one of the russian occupiers said that
they might use chemical weapons against
the defenders of mario paul
we consider it very seriously
i'd like to remind the world leaders
that russia's possible use of chemical
weapons has already been discussed
at that moment it meant that the
reaction to the russian aggression had
to be much more severe and faster
well let's find out what's happening in
kiev should we this morning and standing
by for us is uh deborah again hi deborah
good morning to you
uh concerns that there could be uh have
been uh some sort of chemical attack
where are we with that
well the the figures that you just gave
show that the situation in mario paul
even before these latest allegations was
horrific the idea of 10 000 people
civilians already having been killed
it's a city that has been under siege
since the beginning of this war and the
worry has been as russian forces failed
to take the city could they escalate and
deploy some kind of chemical weapon what
we're hearing so far is nothing
confirmed but it's interesting of course
and notable that the foreign secretary
felt uh it's um it's suitable to tweet
that the uk is urgently working to
verify the details of these reports the
reports about a chemical agent we don't
know exactly what it could be and of
course it's not confirmed yet okay
deborah thank you let's find out if we
can uh what the british government is
aware of james heap minister for armed
forces is with us now hello to you mr
heapey thank you for joining us um
what do we know about this alleged um
attack um apparently uh
reports of a drone people with breathing
issues and dizziness
so nothing more than you're reporting
i'm afraid we know that uh
there are reports of the use of chemical
weapons
we have not been able to verify those
ourselves and indeed the ukrainian
system uh as you've seen from president
zielinski uh are only referring to the
fact that there are reports they
themselves haven't yet been able to
confirm to us that they have been used
the u.s president joe biden said on the
24th of last month that if chemical
attack chemical weapons were used
in ukraine that that was a red line
if it's proven what happens next
well that's exactly right i mean these
are
appalling weapons to even think about
using and the fact that they are
part of the discussion is deeply
sobering it's not just the presence of
the united states the president of
france and our own prime minister have
also been clear that there are
weapons that simply should not be used
and if they are used people will be held
to account i think it's useful to
maintain some ambiguity k over exactly
what the response would be
but let's be clear if they are used uh
at all
then president putin should know that
all possible options are on the table in
terms of how the west might respond
could could we go as far as to say a
considered but effective response
well i it would certainly be effective
but it would also be well considered i
think it's a very good way of putting it
but it's important to
recognize that there are all sorts of
ways in which
these things could be used
from the use of tear gas which is
effectively a riot control measure all
the way through to
utterly devastating lethal
chemical weapon systems so i don't i
don't think it's helpful to be too
binary about the situation because these
are highly nuanced but i also think it's
very important to be very clear with
your viewers who i think have a deep
sense of what is right and what is wrong
that there are some things that are
beyond the pale and the use of chemical
weapons will get a response and all
options are on the table for what that
response could be
as a military man i know that you will
have a view on this the 36th naval
infantry brigade have been doing their
best to try to protect the people of
mario paul and to hold the line
for 47 days now
they have commented
on
their facebook page to say that they are
running out of ammunition
and there is little else that they can
do um a thought for them
just
amazing heroism um within my
within my regiment the rifles one of the
things that um we celebrate the most was
uh what happened in the battle of calais
which was sort of
to hold calais whilst the dunkirk
evacuations were were going on and i i
when i read the stuff from the marines
and mario paul last night i was kind of
reminded of just that the extraordinary
courage that it takes to just keep
fighting as ammunition runs low and you
know that your chances of resupply are
limited and yet your sort of sense of
patriotism your sense of duty to your
country your knowledge that the longer
you fight the longer you hold out the
more opportunity it gives others to be
ready for what comes next i just think
they're amazing people and they
epitomize everything that we've come to
admire about the ukrainian armed forces
over the last six weeks uh lord richard
dannett former head of the british army
who i'm guessing you would have served
under during your time in the military
says that russia is on the brink of
genocide in ukraine what are your
thoughts
i i think that we have seen
the most appalling images brought to us
over the last few weeks as russia you
know this there's something
it's great to see debs haines back in
kiev
it's great to see that keeve is coming
back to some sort of
normality
but as we saw those troops withdrawal
last week from booker and hoster melon
urpin the pictures we saw were just
appalling and yet those are the places
that we've been able to get cameras into
what is what it must look like how many
dead there must be
in the cities and towns that have been
under siege for the last six weeks and
we haven't yet been able to get cameras
into it is just the most monstrous loss
of life that is a deliberate tactic used
by the russians to besiege cities and
impose cost on the civilian population
that has remained um you know lord
danette used
the word genocide i would just say that
whatever is going on in ukraine uh from
the russians is extraordinarily bleak um
and i think that the resolve of the
ukrainian people and president zielinski
to keep fighting and to win back their
territory
is amazing the cost is enormous putin
however will be held to account and so
too will everybody who serves in his
government in the chain of command who
have been responsible for these
atrocities
talk to me about imran khan um if you
would please uh domestic politics um
he's been convicted of um
a sexual act against a child
um
should he resign
well i mean he has been convicted uh
that's happened in a court of la in a
court of law so it's a judgment that of
course we respect he has had the whip
removed and has been uh expelled from
the conservative party the way that
parliament works is that you are elected
as an individual so his seat in the
house of commons
is his until he personally chooses to
vacate it there are mechanisms now
through
recall petitions that have been in place
uh since i think 2015 from from memory
so
if he chooses not to there are now
mechanisms through which he can uh be
removed from his seat and subjected to a
by-election i understand he has plans to
appeal but quite frankly um everybody in
government respects that a court of law
has found him guilty uh and that must be
the judgment until he appeals
successfully well crispin blunt doesn't
does he i mean he's a tory mp he's cr
he's um literally uh talked about how
his friend uh is uh innocent he
describes it as a dreadful miscarriage
of justice and nothing short of an
international scandal does the
government distance themselves from the
comments of one of their own
yes
that's fairly straightforward do you
expect him to retract it
i don't know because i have no idea what
it is that crispin is referring to in
the comments that he said all i know is
that in a court of law yesterday
mr khan was found guilty
and i think every one of us who believes
in the judicial system and the rule of
law
has to respect that judgment and i think
it's for crispin to account for his
words but it's not something the
government associates itself with
um should he keep the whip
again i think that it's for people to
look at today as they speak to crisp and
find out what this is all about but
what matters is that absolutely nobody
in her majesty's government is seeking
to be critical of the decision of the
court
if mr khan chooses to appeal that is for
him but a course of law has found him
guilty and that is what the government
believes him to be there for yeah and
you would be content um if mr khan
decided that the best course of action
was for him to resign um triggering a
by-election
well i think that that is a judgment for
him but as i've said there are now
parliamentary mechanisms to ensure that
people who have been found guilty of
crimes that require a prison sentence
and in fact actually through the recall
position um those who haven't required
to go to prison but have been found
guilty
of a crime
can be subjected to a by-election if
that is the will of their constituents
this is ultimately however a
parliamentary process
mr khan has been removed from the
conservative party and had the whip
removed from his uh from him in
parliament as well
it would be of no concern to
the government if a by-election was
triggered in a red wall seat that was
actually won by the conservatives for
the first time in certainly in a very
long time if if ever and the
ramifications of that oh i mean i see
what you're driving at kate but i i mean
i just don't think the politics is the
most important issue here
is a very good way of putting it um i
wondered if i could ask you about rishi
sunak um are you supportive of the
chancellor and the way he and his wife's
finances are being conducted
yes i am i am i think that he has
uh being clear about what the
arrangements are uh he has recognized
that
even after his reassurances people uh
still wanted some further issuance so
he's referred himself to
lord guyt
but i think rishi is
is pretty straightforward pretty
straight talking and he has been pretty
clear on what the circumstances are
and the fact that the labour leader
describes um his behavior
as uh rank hypocrisy what would be your
response to that
yeah well i i don't think it is
hypocritical because i don't think that
anybody is saying that rishi
hasn't paid the tax that he is supposed
to so i just don't get
where kirstama is coming from with that
comment i also
saw some sort of comment that suggested
that because rishi has been successful
in his life before politics he's
therefore out of touch and i think that
also is ridiculous
you yourself kay i think have on
occasions challenged uh mps and
ministers about their their competence
and whether or not they uh are up to the
job well you know here we've got someone
who has demonstrably been hugely
successful in a career in finance before
entering parliament and is now
responsible for running our economy and
very obviously i want people to be
running the economy who have been very
successful in the financial industry
before coming into politics because
surely they are the best qualified with
all the necessary experience and
expertise but i would have two counters
to that if i may minister one of them
would be um he was a green card holder
so he was resident in another country
while he was deciding what the tax
liability should be for the rest of us
here in the united kingdom i wonder if
you have a thought on that first of all
well whatever the the green card
circumstances are on i have to say i'm
not completely
familiar with how that all works but
even if he was holding a green card
whilst doing the deciding on tax uh in
this country no one's ever suggested
that he's done anything but pay all the
tax that he is required to in the uk
that's very true but my point is that
he's resident of another country which
he was until last october when he was
the chancellor and yet nevertheless he
felt
able to offer his view and indeed law to
decide how we paid our tax and secondly
um i have a friend who is a captain of
industry who is a non-dom but um he
still chooses to pay his tax in the uk
because he says it's the right thing
to do and now i know that mr tsunaki
will come back and say uh does do that
but his wife did not until a spotlight
was shown on that and they have
subsequently decided that they will
change that is that because they are now
doing the right thing and they didn't
previously
well i certainly think they're doing the
right thing now in the i think that it
matters to the british public that
they
think that there or that they know
that their political leaders are
paying their way and paying all of the
taxes that they
are due to but to be clear no one is
suggesting that rishi's wife ever
uh avoided paying tax she paid all the
tax that she needed to on the income she
earned in the uk she had non-domiciled
status because she is a foreign national
and she uh hasn't made herself resident
in the uk for the purposes of tax and
her business she's changed that decision
out of loyalty to her husband's um
political career and there's a sort of
unease if you don't mind me saying that
in 2022 that is still something that she
felt compelled to do to support her
husband but um she never did anything
wrong by being non-dom she is an indian
national
and she pays her tax elsewhere she
changed that out of loyalty to rishi i
think that's very admirable
perhaps all pales um when one thinks
about what's happening in mario paul at
the moment uh but we appreciate you
taking the time to join us on the
programme this morning minister thank
you very much indeed
let's find out what the papers are
saying last stand is the headline in the
metro as ukrainian forces in mariopol
prepare for another onslaught from
russia but with their ammunition
starting to run low
the eye claims an exclusive with details
what it says are russia's plans to
resettle displaced ukrainians in the far
east and the arctic circle
the guardian leads with an attack by
labour leader kia stammer on the
chancellor ishisunak over his wife's tax
affairs accusing him of being an out of
touch hypocrite just put that to the
minister the express leads with a plea
from campaign groups for more help for
pensioners suffering from the huge rise
in the cost of living and the mirror
focuses on the case of one couple who
say they'll never be able to afford to
switch their heating on again
and the mail says that emergency plans
are being drawn up to avoid travel chaos
at ports and airports ruining people's
easter breaks
still to come on the programme for you
this morning 7 30 as fears grow that
russia could be about to deploy chemical
weapons in ukraine going to be joined by
the former chief of the general staff
general lord richard dannet
then at around about 20 to eight joined
by the u.s political commentator and
journalist scotty nell hughes for all
the latest on johnny depp's
multi-million dollar u.s defamation
lawsuit against his ex-wife amber hood
and shortly after eight we'll get
labour's reaction to all of this
morning's developments at home and
overseas with the shadow leader of the
house of commons and that's tangum
debonair
airlines once again under fire for being
woefully understaffed as we heard and
head into the easter weekend with many
cancelling flights last minute well on
monday alone 64 british airways flights
were cancelled 25 easyjet flights were
cancelled yesterday as well let's find
out more about what's going on muddy
standing by for us this morning at
heathrow um hi maddie what's the
prediction for today
good morning kay well the fear is that
the disruption is going to continue all
this week leading up to easter it's what
happens when huge increase in demand for
holidays people booking again meet sharp
staff shortages um during the pandemic
the travel industry thousands and
thousands of jobs were lost as
people just didn't feel confident
booking the restrictions yo-yo'd people
didn't know whether they could go or not
in response jobs were lost and now uh
airline operators airports they're all
trying to hire those staff back we
recruit more staff but it's taking much
longer than they expected they say to
get them vetted to get their security
clearance and so you've got this backlog
people trying to hire um more staff to
help deal with the increase in demand
and it's just not happening quick enough
and that's exacerbated then by um
covered covered absences covered
sickness related atmospheres amongst
their existing staff so it's sort of a
perfect storm
and the fear is it's not going to just
lead up to easter but continue all
summer as it takes a while to get staff
levels back up to pre-pandemic levels
maddie thanks very much indeed thanks a
lot i think the big
key is if you are heading off uh for the
easter break check before you leave the
house breaking news to bring you now
concerning the cost of living crisis
let's find out more should we our
correspondent paul kelso standing by
with the details hey paul tell us more
yeah good morning kay um more news from
the office for national statistics this
morning confirming what many people will
already know from their weekly and
monthly paychecks which is that average
earnings are not keeping up with the
rate of inflation uh the ons say this
morning that uh wages in real terms have
fallen one percent that's minus one
percent in the three months to february
that's despite wage increases on average
at four percent when you include bonuses
for those lucky enough to get them
wage rises are running at five point
four percent but with inflation
running at over six percent is just
simply not enough to keep up with the
real price
of outgoings we know about energy we
know food prices are increasing across
the board so this confirmation that the
price of the standard the cost of living
squeeze is tightening there is slightly
brighter news in these numbers about the
state of the labor market unemployment
has fallen again down to 3.8 but we have
this great curiosity in the labor market
two record figures there are nearly 1.3
million vacancies that's jobs that need
to be filled employers seeking to fill
them and a record number of people on
payrolls almost 30 million so a labor
squeeze
inflation rising employers working it
looks on the face of it quite hard some
of them to keep up with inflation but
not managing to keep the money that
people are being paid in their pockets
to anything like keep up with rising
prices okay thanks very much thank you
paul
looking at some of today's other
headlines on the programme for uni and a
court has heard how a robber threatened
to cut former england footballer ashley
cole's fingers off with pliers during a
violent break-in at his home nottingham
crown court was told the ex-chelsea and
england star was cable-tied and led
around the house in just a pair of
shorts during the ordeal
a four strong gang who in january 2020
smashed their way into cole's home with
a sledgehammer before stealing jewellery
and mobile phones
more than half of the global population
are affected by headaches every year the
results published in the journal of
headache and pain suggest more than half
of the world's population have an active
headache disorder typically described as
experiencing some type of headache
during the past year
a group of senior mps has warned the
government needs much more ambition and
focus to tackle the shocking collapse in
rape prosecutions the commons home
affairs committee says unacceptably low
numbers of suspects being taken to court
for rape and sexual offence will
continue without stronger reforms to the
criminal justice system
the u.s has ordered its non-emergency
consular staff to leave shanghai amid
unrest over covert 19 measures let's
find out more should we standing by for
us in beijing it's tom hi tom good
morning to you so uh this isn't this
the latest from uh the us is that they
want some of their stuff out because
they're unsure about what happens next
yeah exactly that okay um last week they
said that anyone who wanted to leave uh
could leave shanghai from the consulate
there uh what they're saying today is
that everyone who's non-emergency has to
leave that's how worried they are about
what's happening there and you wouldn't
really want to be in shanghai right now
we've seen the scenes of luton we've
seen people locked in their compounds
demanding more food from the government
and i think uh also the issue that was
raised last week of separation
of children from their parents in cases
of positive cover tests that's all
contributed to this decision it's likely
to go badly to go down badly rather with
the chinese government they criticized
that advice last week so this mandatory
evacuation with staff leaving on
commercial flights um isn't going to go
down well with the chinese foreign
ministry um they're trying to put a
different spin on things in shanghai we
did see a drop in cases for the first
time in about two weeks so 25 000 odd
cases registered in the last 24 hours so
that might suggest it's on the way to
some uh sort of permanent decrease and
what we're also seeing is some residents
have been allowed outside of their
locked rooms and now allowed to walk
around it's either inside their
residential compounds or perhaps even
onto the street i mean nothing's open in
shanghai it is still in lockdown
effectively but science perhaps of life
the bigger worry is what's happening
really all across china whether those
scenes in shanghai will be repeated with
lots of other cities building those
quarantine centers uh those sort of
things you're seeing on your screen
right now there's huge exhibition halls
where space for thousands of people and
that's the chinese approach there are
ways that approach is costing lika chang
the chinese prime minister warning of
increased downward pressure on the
economy but there's no chance that
despite that china is going to give up
on its dynamic zero covered policy
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show here on sky news
tuesday morning in the last half an hour
the armed forces minister has told this
program the government is keeping all
options on the table after the foreign
secretary uh it says that the uk is
investigating new reports of a possible
chemical attack in mariopol james heapey
also told me he believes the use of
chemical weapons are beyond the pale
it's important to
recognize that there are all sorts of
ways in which
these things could be used
from the use of tear gas which is
effectively a riot control measure all
the way through to
utterly devastating lethal
chemical weapon system so i don't i
don't think it's helpful to be too
binary about the situation because these
are highly nuanced but i also think it's
very important to be very clear with
your viewers who i think have a deep
sense of what is right and what is wrong
that there are some things that are
beyond the pale and the use of chemical
weapons will get a response and all
options are on the table for what that
response could be
ali is here no messing around there no
all options on the table i think he was
very clear that if
these reports are verified and we know
that that's something the foreign office
are doing
this is going to be a very serious
moment and potentially a moment of
worrying escalation we know that
chemical weapons were really a line um
that the west did not want russia red
line i think a red line exactly yeah
you're right he said that it will
trigger a response in kind we heard
james heapy there saying that we need to
retain a level of ambiguity over what
exactly that means but he did say um
that it is beyond the pale and that all
options as you say are on the table so i
think it is a very worrying moment in
this war he also talked about um a
former conservative mp i mean he's still
an mp at the moment uh an independent mp
because the whip has been removed and
whether or not he should talking about
the fact that he was um convicted of
child sex offense yesterday whether or
not he should resign now that would
trigger a by-election wouldn't it
yes so it's it's a bit complicated but
the only way that imran khan who is of
course
the mp for wakefield won that seat one
of the moments of the election night in
2019 the only way he will go now is if
he gets a custodial sentence of more
than a year that means automatically
there will be a by-election in wakefield
or if he chooses to resign or if he gets
a custodial sentence of less than a year
that could trigger what's known as a
recall petition which means enough of
his constituents want him gone then
there will be a by-election so that is
um that is interesting particularly i
think given that this is a red wool seat
the sort of seat that labour really need
to be winning if they want to do well in
the general election but i think you
also have the extraordinary backlash
after christian blunts um
support
overwhelming support yesterday for um
for imran khan he tweeted to call this a
miscarriage of justice that is something
that james hippie clearly wanted to show
that the government were distanced from
he said that that is not a view held by
anyone in his majesty's government he
said absolutely no one in his majesty's
government is seeking to be critical of
the decision of the court were saying a
tory source has suggested to us that we
expect that statement from christian
blunt might be retracted this morning
and you will be speaking to him very
shortly uh not christman blunt actually
speaking of chris bryant yeah yeah but
if crispin blunt's watching this morning
please feel free to come and talk to us
on the program very interested to hear
um what you have to say about those
comments that you made yesterday or
whether indeed you will be uh
withdrawing them mr blunt that's
certainly the view that we are hearing
this morning and chris bryant who has
resigned along with three others as a
result
of his comments we'll be chatting to him
as you quite rightly say ali
in the next hour
uh meantime let's find out more
about the latest developments in ukraine
and we're joined by the former chief of
the general staff general lord richard
dunnett hello my lord thank you for
joining us on the programme your
reaction first of all this morning if i
may
uh on the suggestions that there has
been a chemical attack not yet confirmed
in mariopol
well okay i think this is quite possible
that at some point the russians might
decide to use chemical weapons
i think we also have to look at who's
now in command of the operation in the
east of of ukraine um general alexander
dornikov
who
established a pretty fearsome reputation
uh in syria and
certainly in syria
there is clear evidence that
he and russian forces
in support of the syrians use chemical
weapons so i'm afraid it's quite
possible that we might see chemical
weapons being used um the reports are
unconfirmed at the present moment but i
think as james heapey said earlier
something like this is beyond the pale
but it's not beyond possibility
and
being beyond the pale as france the west
is concerned it's been described as a
red line issue we're just hearings
discussed uh there by a president biden
at the end of last month our prime
minister has said the same but what does
that mean what options are available if
that is the case
well this is where
again as james heapey said they want to
keep a degree of ambiguity about what
they actually mean i think here the two
nato has been quite sensible not to set
firm hard red lines because once you set
a red line
and say if this action takes place then
we will do this that or the other um and
if you do cross that red line then you
become a bit hollow if you don't carry
out that action now what um the west has
got in mind is
open to interpretation is deliberately
uh
ambiguous i mean i think there's a whole
range of things that can be done um
yes it sounds a bit soft to say to
significantly increase once again uh
economic sanctions and sanctions on uh
senior leaders uh in uh in in russia
stepping up even further the weapons
being made available to the ukrainian
army but again that's already being done
then then you have to get into the sort
of realm of
speculation um would nato really choose
to get actively involved using
major weapons below the nuclear
threshold we certainly wouldn't use
chemical weapons ourselves that would be
a contrary to everything that nato has
ever stood for so there is a degree of
ambiguity there but again the west has
got to make it absolutely clear just as
we are accusing russia quite properly of
of war crimes the indiscriminate
shelling of civilians which they've been
carrying out very widely that we that we
know about
pressure has got to be continued to be
piled on putin and his senior people
that there are some things that are
totally unacceptable and some things
that fall somewhat more within the rules
of war but virtually everything the
russians have been doing is pretty much
outside the conventions of war currently
you've you've spoken um the last couple
of times i've spoken to you my lord
about um on the edge of genocide
if i were to press you again this
morning
well i think they are closer still
the accounts that are emerging
particularly from the north now that the
russian troops have withdrawn from the
areas around kiev a number of the things
that have been reported and well
documented now
very much add up certainly to war crimes
and when you put a large list of war
crimes together you have to ask yourself
the question what is all this about are
they actually trying to remove this
whole group of people
by which i mean um the ukrainian
population itself
we know that russia wants to control
ukraine but it's an awful thought to
actually even consider do they want to
control ukraine without its people
everything that they are doing and this
is what we're seeing now
with this suggestion of chemical weapons
is to force the people to flee from
their homes free from their areas
and
it all does add up to an increasing
catalogue of war crimes that
increasingly looks like it looks like
genocide and and
and i've said this before okay
whether we'll ever put putin in a court
of law i don't know but the court of
history will absolutely damn him when
the full record comes out
yes um talk to me about the uh refugee
scheme particularly as it relates to the
united kingdom i know that you from
personal experience are um pretty
disappointed about it
well okay you're right i mean we all
know that a tremendous number of people
have been displaced internally uh in
ukraine and a very large number have now
left ukraine whether or not they
actually want one day to go home isn't
really the issue but they need safety
and sanctuary and european union
countries have been pretty open armed if
you like in accepting ukrainian refugees
united kingdom by contrast has put
together
despite what the rhetoric from the
government is we've put together a
pretty complicated system the
form-filling is very onerous um and if i
say there are ridiculous things such as
um or should i say it would be much
better if a family only had to make one
application typically it's a mother and
one or two or three children filling in
one application but we've got a
situation uh whereby
even a two or three year old child has
to have a separate application and
answer quite ridiculous questions for a
two-year-old child um asking what sort
of former employment that they have been
in have they been involved in the armed
forces well
typically quite obviously this is not
and all this has translated into a very
large number of applications being
processed by the uk visa and immigration
service um at a speed that's
horrendously slow um
i'm personally
involved with a group of six ukrainians
who have managed to get uh out of
ukraine they originally got into krakow
where they filled in their application
forms they've now made their way across
europe
into an airbnb in dunkirk and they will
cross over to this country to homes that
are ready and waiting for them including
my own um but they haven't got their
visas and um although one's tried to
elevate
this six their case for example um
it's rather like um whistling into a
howling gale
one doesn't seem to be able to get a
response from the authorities at all i
think we really have to look at our
system look and see if we can simplify
it and it is jolly complicated we can
see if we can simplify it so that we can
be genuinely welcoming to people who
have been through terrible trauma and
there are homes in this country where
they can be safe and secure and welcomed
we really must do that for these people
and not just talk about it
so the beds are ready um at your lovely
home in norfolk you just can't get the
ukrainian people who um you've promised
them to over the border what would you
say to the prime minister in a sentence
this morning we know they watch the show
i would say look urgently at the system
that we are using ask ourselves whether
it's too complicated ask ourselves
whether we've got enough people working
the system to make sure that
applications are handled and processed
as quickly as possible frankly it is
taking too long
larissa and bowdan beaubor are in an
airbnb in dunkirk when we have bedrooms
and
facilities here ready to welcome them
let's just get the paperwork done then
they can travel and maybe they can have
a decent easter weekend as opposed to
being stuck
where they are at the present moment
in the meantime we are hearing that
russia um as a final thought from you uh
lord and it
are taking hundreds of thousands of
ukrainians across the border against
their will into russia my understanding
is that that is also a war crime is that
right
well if people are being taken to where
they don't want to go um in an enforced
manner yes that is a war crime um under
the rules of war civilians have an
absolute right to be protected
and to be removed to russia if they
don't want to go to russia
is indeed another version of a war crime
and i'm afraid kay we're going to see an
intensification
of the fighting in the east quite
sensibly the ukraine government has been
urging people to leave and to come west
to get away from the area of fighting
and we're going to see a very
concentrated
russian attack over the next few days
and weeks because putin is determined to
have some kind of victory that he can
celebrate
on the 9th of may their armed forces
victory day
yeah indeed so 9th of may coming up very
soon uh thank you very much indeed for
joining us as usual my lord thank you
hopefully
those refugees and that you are
hopefully offering at home too will be
with you before too long thank you
thanks kate hope to see you
um so we're hearing as i just said that
400 000 people in ukraine have been
taken across the border to russia
against their will meantime allegations
of a chemical
attack in mario paul which is urgently
being investigated by the west what on
earth is happening in moscow diana
magnay standing by
militia units from the self-declared
donetsk people's republic moving through
what's left of mariupol
ukrainian forces surrounded preparing
for what they call today the final
battle
and even these russian-backed
separatists admit it's been a hard fight
as russia's ministry of defense released
fresh video claiming they'd taken out
more ukrainian positions russia's
foreign minister told state tv there
would be no let up in the fight
russians have rallied behind their
president over these past six weeks his
approval ratings even with independent
pollsters now at more than 80 per cent
are you worried about what's happening
in ukraine what russia is doing
but it will still be some time before
the economic squeeze from sanctions
really kicks in
and when it does the kremlin will have
one message for its people however
untrue that is
that none of this was our fault
diana mcnair sky news moscow
situation with ukraine causing some
problems at the pumps here as well
problems with fuel getting into the uk
via europe from russia 1200
fuel pumps have now been closed in the
uk also problems with extinction
rebellions so what does that mean for
you and me as we head towards the easter
weekend fairfield uk campaign howard cox
is with us hi howard um good to talk to
you um how concerned are you about
what's going on
good morning thanks for having me on
yeah we're i'm getting bombarded with
emails and communicates from supporters
and drivers across the country who have
thoroughly fed up with what's going on
there's really no need to do this uh
protesting i'm all for their objectives
a sound it's not a problem but to
actually interfere with the fuel supply
chain and especially approaching easter
when there's 20 it's probably one of the
most busiest weekends on the road uh
it's going to cause chaos and and
problems that we're already facing
higher fuel prices and uh ridiculously
high fuel prices and and these
protesters are making it worse it seems
to be a fashion to them
um i went to fill up my vehicle
yesterday actually enough to say of
about i think there were 40 pumps and
only four of them actually had fuel um i
suppose you have to start to be anxious
that we're going to be seeing um fuel
rationing potentially what's your advice
to motorists
well obviously
it's pot luck at the moment where
particularly in rural areas you're
finally in the south everything below
the midlands et cetera is being hit most
because that's where most of the
protests are and from the oil depots
what my advice to most is to be patient
uh take your time dude there isn't the
fuel is available and it's going to get
there it's not a problem there's no need
to panic by but at the moment in time
what we should be seeing is the
government doing much more to stop
making sure the fuel supply chain is
secure and protected
and and what form would that take uh for
you because of course
these protesters would say they're
acting on behalf of all of us because
they're trying to save the planet
well they're not acting on
on behalf of all of us the majority of
people want to go around their normal
life go to work take their kids to
school go to hospitals et cetera they
need their vehicles especially in rural
areas where public transport is pretty
poor
they need to recognize that their
approach for protesting is actually
alienating their argument it's not
working well what we need to do and i
challenge them i'm happy to sit down in
front of a sky camera with these
protesters and talk about the issues
they're talking about and i would
actually give them the science not the
emotion
what do you want
the government to do
well i'm pleased to see that uh
kierstama's labour party have actually
called for injunctions on these people
we need those and we need more police
actually policing these depots to allow
the tankers to get out
to to deliver the government must do
more than that talk is cheap i hear ben
wallace is saying it's terrible and i
hear pretty patel that these eco uh
terrorists uh they are eco terrorists we
should stop them but they're not doing
enough the talk is cheap they've got to
get out there and make sure our roads
are clear for tankers to travel down to
deliver old fuels to our four courts